- Quelques pas hésitants dans
un Gaza étrangement calme.
Au petit matin, peu après
l'entrée en vigueur du cessez-
le-feu, Hasan Alyan et sa petite
famille ont remis le nez
après être restés 11 jours
terrés dans cette école.
Le long chemin du retour
à la maison est l'occasion
de constater les dégâts.
L'intense campagne de
bombardement de l'armée
israélienne a laissé des traces.
D'après les autorités
palestiniennes, 17 000 logements
ont été endommagés, 1000
complètement détruits.
Et la maison d'Hasan n'a pas
été épargnée.
"Regardez ces débris
et toute cette vitre cassée",
se désole-t-il avant
d'entreprendre de tout nettoyer,
de tout réparer, car la vie
doit continuer.
(pleurs)
Difficile cependant
pour les familles épleurées
de tourner la page.
Les bombes israéliennes ont fait
243 morts dont beaucoup
de femmes et d'enfants.
Autant de victimes saluées
comme des martyrs par le Hamas
qui présente le cessez-le-feu
comme une victoire stratégique
de la résistance face à
l'occupant israélien.
"Un pas de géant dans
l'histoire du conflit, selon le
chef du Hamas, Ismaïl Haniyeh.
Une victoire proclamée aussi
par le premier ministre
israélien.
Benyamin Nétanyahou affirme
avoir atteint ses objectifs
en détruisant le réseau de
tunnel du Hamas et en tuant
25 de ses hauts dirigeants.
Le camp israélien déplore
quand même 12 morts et beaucoup
de dégâts matériels.
(chants)
Mais la trêve reste fragile.
La situation est très tendue.
Moins d'une demi-journée
après le cessez-le-feu,
des affrontements ont à nouveau
éclaté entre manifestants
palestiniens et policiers
israéliens. Des affrontements
sur l'esplanade des Mosquées
à Jérusalem après la prière du
vendredi, comme ceux qui ont mis
le feu aux poudres il y a de
cela deux semaines.
Les bombes et les roquettes
ont cédé la place aux pierres,
au gaz lacrymogène et aux balles
de caoutchouc, mais la tension
et l'inimitié entre les deux
peuples n'a pas changé.
Ici Jean-François Bélange